always been people have been taught that
they must work hard nobody told them
they must work joyfully there is no best
thing to do in life anything that you
take up and if you put your heart and
soul into it it becomes a great thing
it's time that human potential is
unleashed because we are the first
generation on the planet for whom our
survival is organized better than ever
before need motivation watch a top 10
with belief nation
he Satguru and here's my take on his top
50 rules for success okay let's kick it
off with rule number one enhance your
perception and intelligence effort has
to be incisive in the sense it should be
focused calibrated believe you make
effort it's foolish effort isn't it just
labor is not going to get you somewhere
right kind of action the right timing
right place all this is important isn't
it so for all these things to happen you
need perception and intelligence so
that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception and your intelligence
the rest will anyway happen this is one
thing that unfortunately humanity is not
doing they're trying to become capable
of something do not try to become
capable of something just enhance your
perception and intelligence rule number
two
take charge of your life can you see me
right now all of you can you see me just
point out where I am use your hands and
point out can you see me
are you got it wrong you know I am a
mystic you're getting it completely
wrong now this light is falling upon me
reflecting going through your lenses
inverted image in your retina you know
the whole story right where do you see
me right now within yourself where do
you hear me right now within yourself
where have you seen the whole world
within yourself have you ever
experienced anything outside of yourself
everything that ever happened to you
darkness and light happened within you
pain and pleasure happened within
joy and misery happened within you have
you ever experienced anything outside of
yourself no so what I am asking you is
what happens within you who should
determine how it should happen what
happens within you who should determine
how this should happen somebody else
definitely you should determine what
should happen within this isn't it so if
you determine what's happening within
this your whole experience of life will
be determined by you nobody else but you
isn't it the events around you may not
be determined by you but how your
experience of life is on this planet is
100% determined by you if you take
charge of this if you leave it loose
just about anybody will determinate they
will not consciously they also like you
by accident rule number three be
conscious of your mortality if you you
should just observe if everybody makes
an little effort everybody take a little
time for this piece of life okay
not for your family not for your carrier
not for something else something else
just for this piece of life give it
little time because this is the most
important piece of life in your life
isn't it yes or no yeah even if you're
in love with somebody still this is the
most important piece of life isn't it so
pay some attention to this how does it
happen why have you taken it for granted
believe me you're not going to be here
forever
I'll bless you with a long life but
you're going to fall dead one day yes or
no so do not take this for granted if
you wake up in the morning tomorrow if
you wake up in the morning
now it's not my wish but I want you to
know of all the people who go to bed
tonight over a million people will not
wake up tomorrow morning and tomorrow if
you and me wake up tomorrow morning is
it not a fantastic thing a million
people did not wake up you woke up is it
not a great thing just look at the
ceiling and smile you are still awake
you still there
and for many many millions of people
somebody whose dear to them did not wake
up so just check those five six people
around you they all woke up Wow it's a
fantastic day you woke up and everybody
who matters to you around you woke up is
it not fantastic day you don't think so
yes you don't seem to think so because
the problem is just this you are living
with an idea that you are immortal when
I say you're immortal you're not
actually thinking you're immortal but
you are not conscious of your morale a
mortality if you are not conscious of
your mortality somewhere you think
you're immortal isn't it how many
moments in a day are you conscious that
you're mortal if you were conscious
would you have time to crib would you
have time to fight with somebody would
you have time to do some rubbish with
your life if you knew if you are
conscious that you're mortal you will do
nothing other than what is absolutely
needed for you and everybody around you
this one thing if you do if you just
remind yourself you don't think this is
a negative thing that is not a negative
thing it's the only thing which is added
value to your life if you are here
forever
you would be unbearable yeah
yes you did aren't we glad everybody
dies one day if you just become
conscious of this one thing that always
you're conscious that I'm mortal you
don't have to think I will die today we
don't intend we want to live as far as
possible just you know one day I will
die if you just conscious of this one
thing you will naturally become
spiritual every day every moment if you
remind yourself this is a brief life and
motto one day I will end just do this
for two days and see you will become
something truly fantastic within
yourself just this is all and simply
beautiful that's all that's needed if
you want to know the value of life just
know that it's a brief happening rule
number four take a holiday from
seriousness just loosen up your life a
little bit laugh a little more involve
yourself with people around you
do things that you think is not so
important don't do things which are very
important do simple things very
important you do simple things very
important things you're doing in your
life you will become dead serious
you know Bertrand Russell and Englishman
Bertrand Russell said if you're
beginning to think that what you are
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to
Indiana holiday is every day in those 24
hours you must take a holiday from your
seriousness from yourself seriousness
has come essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust in this
existence tomorrow morning if you
disappear for sure in India nobody will
miss you even Down Under they won't
bother much you know a handful of people
they will also forget soon enough units
ooh nature does woof you're gone and
nothing will happen in this world
everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not they every human
being should be aware of this every
moment of his life it does not matter
what the whole world says about you it
does not matter how significant the work
you're doing you must understand that
tomorrow morning the world will go on
fine without you whoever you may be
isn't it so if you constantly remind
yourself of this you'll have no reason
to be serious definitely not dead and
don't be dead
now a time will come it's time to be
alive also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link to
join is in the description below it's
easy to make a buck very hard to make a
difference you have to work with people
where you feel a bit insecure that's
essential because that means you're
working with people who are better than
you
rule number five produce nice movies to
create fear you have to use excessive
imagination do not be in fear you don't
have to do anything real is happening
because of the excessive imagination
things that have not happened you're
creating what may happen in your mind
happens in thousand different formats
and most probably it never happens the
things that you feared take hundred
things that you have feared probably 99
of them never happened isn't it yes
so you're here your fear is always about
that which does not exist you cannot
fight or you cannot overcome that which
does not exist
we can overcome something with that
exists you cannot overcome that which
does not exist you just have to give up
that effort enjoy the fear after all
it's your making you like horror movies
yes I mean you're saying no but you do
producing them just they're not making
money that's all fear means you're
producing horror movies in your mind
nobody else is willing to watch that's
bad for the producer but you're
producing them so you produce something
else that is a comedy a love story
suspense thriller try and see today
just sit down but use a love story a
suspense thriller a comedy fire five
minutes more movies you make in your
mind really start using your mind
differently it is gotten into your
pattern just gotten to your pattern of
just creating oral movies all the time
you have watched enough horror movies
the boring create something else even
it's not that if you produce these
movies those things will happen in your
life still they may not happen at least
you enjoy the movie in reality it may
not happen so what at least you enjoy
what's happening in your mind if you
cannot enjoy what's happening in the
world isn't it that matter privilege
every human being deserves isn't it so
even if the world is not kind to him at
least his own mind should be kind to him
should produce some nice movies rule
number six don't identify yourself with
anything
we are completely committed to one
dimension of our intelligence which we
call as the intellect which is just the
thought process thought can only happen
with the data that you have gathered
through five
which is very limited one thing another
thing is the nature of data that the
census gathered are only useful for
survival process the very nature of how
you see things how you hear smell and
taste and touch life is only relevant
for survival process if you wanting to
know the life itself then these
instruments of perception are no good
even what is light and darkness is a
debate between you and another creature
which sees darkness as light isn't it if
you sit within an owl and start an
argument as to which is light and which
is darkness it's an endless argument but
who do you think is right hello if
you're saying both you're either in the
diplomatic corps or or you have a
successful marriage
[Applause]
you'll learn to say both both but which
is the truth what I see is the truth or
what the owl sees is the truth that's
not the point it is just that nature is
opened up our sense perception as it is
necessary for our survival accordingly
it is opened up sense perceptions for
different creatures as it is necessary
for their survival but if survival is
all you're seeking this is good enough
the five senses but once you have come
as a human being
somehow survival is not good enough if
your stomach is empty there's only one
issue about food but once the stomach
becomes full you have a hundred issues
going on so the nature of the human
being is such no matter what you do you
want to be something more than what you
are right now
and if that's something more happens
something more something more it's an
endless pursuit so somewhere a human
being is seeking a limitless expansion
but trying to do it with physical means
the very nature of physicality is a
defined boundary if there is no defined
boundary there is no possibility of
physical happening in the universe but
now a human being is longing for the
boundless that - in installments and
through physical means through the
boundary you're trying to become
boundless the desire is fantastic the
method is hopeless because the moment
you identify yourself with something
your intellects work is just to protect
that identity if you whatever the
identities of nation or family or gender
or race religion whatever the moment you
identify yourself with something your
intellect will only function around that
to protect that so it is a certain type
of prejudice the moment you are
identified so the only thing I did with
my life is I never identified myself
with anything and life just exploded
within me
in ways that thought seems so puny that
I do not indulge in thought most of the
time rule number seven fix yourself
pleasantness is the choice isn't it so
why is it so much unpleasantness is
happening in human experience because we
never took charge of the inner dimension
we believe by fixing the outside
everything is going to be okay in the
last hundred hundred fifty years with
the advent of science and modern
technology we have fixed too many things
on the outside if you fix anymore there
won't be a planet left yes definitely
this has brought much convenience and
comfort to our lives in every way we are
the most comfortable generation ever you
agree with me I know you have series of
complaints about how things are not okay
but we are the most comfortable
generation ever before on this planet
isn't it so but we cannot say we are the
most joyful generation on the planet we
are the most loving generation on the
planet we are the most blissed-out
generation the plant definitely not we
are complaining complaining like crazy
about everything like never before this
is because we fix the outside comfort
inconvenience has happened well-being
has not happened if your interior tea
was handled by you consciously you would
definitely keep this in a blissful state
so is bliss the goal of life no bliss is
a necessary condition for life to flower
to its full potential otherwise it will
remain constrained rule number eight pay
attention to yourself
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this farm but the quality
of your life is essentially determined
by how you carry this one yes or no this
moment what kind of clothes you're
wearing what kind of car you parked
outside
what kind of home you live in does not
determine the quality of your life
this moment how joyful are you feeling
within yourself determines the quality
of your life isn't it so nothing has
been done about it you think it'll
happen in consequence and you're setting
impossible goals for your happiness if I
have to be happy my wife should be like
this my husband should be like that my
children should be like this the world
should become some other way well these
are impossible conditions you're setting
for your happiness and peacefulness now
that you have compromised yourself to
peace why I'm saying compromise yourself
to pc's because a lot of people have
given up aspirations for being ecstatic
or blissful if I'm just peaceful it's
enough even the so-called spiritual
leaders are going about him saying peace
is the highest goal in your life peace
is not the highest goal in your life if
you want to enjoy your lunch today
you must be peaceful yes or no if you're
not even peaceful there is nothing in
your life that you can do in a
worthwhile way to be peaceful
essentially means this that you're not
messing your mind to be peaceful means
that your system is of ease you know how
to conduct your mind you know how to
conduct your emotions your body and your
energies you are peaceful it is not a
rocket technology it is the most basic
thing you have a dog at home you give
him his food he sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic but please Fellini
times they're ecstatic also yes if your
dog is able to sit pee so he doesn't
have to run my industry that's not the
point he's got his own stuff going
[Music]
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing it's
got something to do with the internal
systems as to how they're functioning
essentially it means he that neither
your body now your mind or your
chemistry nor emotions nor energy are
taking instructions from you they're
doing their own thing once your machine
is not in your control being post
peaceful is impossible I will tell you
you get into your car and now you go
there and you want to turn this way you
do this to the steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car
can you no anxiety is natural isn't it
this is what has happened to your
vehicle it's out of control you never
done anything to find out where the
steering wheel is first of all this is
not that simple as a car this is a super
super computer now the problem is most
people have not even bothered to find
the keyboard they think if they do this
somehow it will work if you make when
you are given such a highly
sophisticated machine if you do not
conduct it properly
it will cause many problems to you by
accident it's working I want you to know
this this is made this way if you hold
your hands like this
it'll breathe one way if you just turn
it around the very way you breathe the
breathing pattern itself changes in your
lungs
you can try it if you want when you have
the time this way this way I'm saying
everything that you do fundamental
changes are happening in this machine
because it's such a sophisticated
machine it's more than a touchscreen if
you just wish it it will happen when you
have such a sensitive and sophisticated
machine and you are operating like a
blacksmith then being peaceful seems to
be difficult peace is not the highest
goal in your life it is the most
fundamental requirement don't ever set
peace as the highest goal if you do that
you'll only rest in peace
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it if you want
to do anything sensibly in your life if
you want to do conduct any situation in
your life sensibly to be peaceful and
happy is fundamental rule a benign do
not set incentives for sickness
unfortunately in many ways not just in
the way that I said now in many
different ways I would say 70% of
illnesses on the planet all kinds our
self-created even if you get an
infection there is a way if you keep
yourself in a certain way physically and
mentally the virus in the bacteria will
not work the same way as it works upon
somebody else if you set yourself like
this no matter what's happening anyway I
have to go and do this this and this
there's no break from that the last 29
years I have not been able to cancel one
program because I'm running temperature
I got a cold I got this I got that it
doesn't matter what's happening what you
have to do you anyway have to do you
can't turn back on that either out of
your commitment or you have a boss like
that one or one way or the other if it
happens then you will see you will not
at all fall sick so often because if you
have temperature you still have to go if
it's somehow you still go right now a
lot of people don't go it's a little hot
outside they don't go on work little
cold outside they don't go on work a
little raining they won't go on work
that's no flake they will not go and
work this is just weather so for every
change in weather if you have the
comfort of cowering yourself in a
blanket and lying down once you create
that your body will learn to
all sick as often as possible if you
just keep it this way it doesn't matter
what it is anyway I have to go and do
what I have to do you will see your body
will just bounce back and as quickly as
possible even if it gets the worst kind
of infections so you just have to set
the necessary conditions for health
necessary in incentives for health both
for yourself and your children if you
have them do not set incentives for
sickness
rule number 10 have a sense of humor
I was speaking in Nashville a few years
ago I was just telling them a joke in
the joke I referred to God as him
immediately a few ladies stood up do you
believe God is a man oh I know where
it's going I was only telling you Duke
it doesn't matter you said him do you
believe God is a man I said I was only
telling your joke
it doesn't matter so now there is an
argument going around in certain parts
of America he's got a man or a woman in
India we have no such problems we have a
man god we have a woman god we have a
cow God we have an elephant God we have
a monkey we have a snake we have flying
one is crawling one's creeping ones
every kind because it's a very wise
culture we foresaw all the future
problems that may arise rule number 11
work joyfully you can live life with
ease
not with struggle one thing is when we
say work it's many young people
wonderful people who getting recognized
for whatever wonderful things they have
done living them apart but generally
work means always been people have been
taught that they must work hard nobody
told them they must work joyfully nobody
told them their work should be an
expression of their joy or their love
they have to work hard if you work hard
life will be tedious how will this how
else will it be you will do something
hard only because you don't know how to
do it if you know how to do it you do it
with these so without learning how to do
something if we try to do it without
investing enough time and perception if
life is all expression then life becomes
a big struggle rule number 12 be
fearless
another single day passes for me right
without witnessing tears of joy and love
around me every day somebody will be
shedding tears of love enjoy I don't
think there's a better way to live in
this world and all of us should strive
to create our own circles of joyfulness
and pleasantness around us
because if you are not joyful by your
own nature if you are always going
around with the fear of suffering as
long as fear of suffering is there
within you you will never walk your life
with full stride it'll always be half a
step most human beings have crippled
themselves simply because of fear of
suffering what will happen to me is
always the question whatever happens
this is how I will be if this assurance
comes to you only now you will want to
scale the peaks of life and see what
about it if it happens makes no
difference to you if it doesn't happen
makes no difference to you that's when
you would like to really explore every
dimension of life so first and foremost
thing is this that your way of being is
not determined by what's around you if
you bring this one aspect to you there
is no fear of suffering once there is no
fear of suffering you will traverse the
breadth and length of this life without
hesitation
number 13 always do your best when the
result of an event has no impact on you
both ways you blissed-out you are a
success when the fruit of when the fruit
of the action does not determine how you
are it's just that you do things because
of the exhibits of what you do then you
are a success the result may depend on
variety of things results have not
always yours results for any result to
happen whether it's in a game or in life
situations the various factors involved
not all of it is in our control but what
is in our control is either we did our
best or we did not do our best that's in
our control as long as we're doing that
and whatever the result may be if you
are still blissed-out that means you are
a success because life cannot defeat you
any more the number 14 be playful being
playful
always has been understood as a
responsibility yes do you know right
from your childhood and probably to your
children also you're doing this if
they're just playful you think it's
irresponsible the most responsible way
to live is that you're playful with life
it's absolutely irresponsible to carry a
long face and walk around in this planet
yes or no isn't it absolutely
irresponsible to walk around with misery
yes that's the most irresponsible thing
you can do
so being playful is not irresponsibility
bling being playful is being very
responsible and responsive to life only
when you're playful you can do that when
you're serious the world doesn't exist
for you you and your nonsense yes when
you're serious it's just about you and
your nonsense the world and other life
does not exist for you only when you are
playful you can pay attention to
everything you can truly respond to
everything in the world only if you are
playful otherwise you cannot just the
burden of it will kill you rule number
15 reach your fullest potential how to
convey fear and apathy okay
fear about with that I will be
successful or not
where is apathy coming know your
individual fear about whether I will be
successful or not is that what you're
talking see that's that's exactly what I
have been telling you till now
do not even think of success just
enhance your capabilities strive to
enhance who you are and what you can do
you'll anyway - isn't it right now you
have an idea of success but you don't
have the competence for that you want to
go somewhere but you don't have the legs
to get there now naturally there
fear naturally there'll be all kinds of
unnecessary struggles and emotions
instead that at this stage in your life
if you just focus on seeing how to
enhance this human being to the highest
possible level that you can success will
be a downhill run not an uphill task so
if you are going downhill there is no
fear isn't it because whether I can get
there or not way that I can get there or
not you are working towards somebody
else's idea of success you're working
towards somebody else's idea of success
that is not success your success is you
as a human being you found your full
potential this is your success and
that's all you can do whether you stand
on your head or you stand on your feet
the best that you can do if this human
being finds is fullest potential that's
all you can do no matter what you do you
cannot do more isn't it
certain circumstances sometimes will
laughters up certain circumstances
sometimes may not but in the given
circumstance if you have blossom to your
fullest level you will do well is it
don't think of success and be fearful
about it just see how to make this one
more and more capable if the competence
and capability is there
success will come as we deserve it rule
number 16 have balanced all human
experiences generated from within is the
term all human experience is generated
or imbued in so at any time if you feel
happy or unhappy miserable joyful
ecstatic
in a state of agony doesn't matter what
happens what is your experience
pleasantness or unpleasantness just to
know that it's happening from within and
it can only happen from within you can
either take external stimuli or you can
create your own stimuli but essentially
it happens from within this one thing if
it is not grasped when you feel
miserable if you think it's this one
you're gone you just the keyboard is
here but you're punching the wall this
is not going to work this one basic
fundamental thing is something that
almost 90% of the humanity is always
doing it wrong whenever they feel
miserable if they think it must be this
one or that one or that one or that one
now all human experience is generated
from within if something is feeling
unpleasant first thing is to look at
this what am I doing wrong with this am
i eating wrong am i sleeping wrong am I
sitting wrong am i breathing wrong is my
heart beating wrong something my very
chemistry is wrong something is wrong
with this not with that so the moment
you think by kicking the wall you can
fix this one then you made a fundamental
mistake the harder you try the further
away from it you go the first thing is
to bring balance once there is balance
then you can build a tower on top of
this if there is no balance whatever you
build will only lead to more trouble the
more basic you are the better it is so
this is what a whole lot of humanity is
seeking somehow to really remain basic
because if you build something it feels
terrible when there is no fundamental
balance anything standing up without
balance is a big problem rule number 17
define success for yourself it is
somebody's idea of what is success isn't
it don't become a slave to somebody's
idea at least have your own idea you
have no idea of your own don't deceive
yourself every idea every thought every
emotion every value that you have is
picked up from some
and it rules you from within it rules
you from within your religion your
society your culture has trained you to
believe that this is it so first the
first and foremost success is that you
are not a slave to anybody's idea this
is success rule number 18 be fully alive
you come to the idea of mortality once
in a way it'll make you depressed it
will make you fearful if you live with
it every moment it will make you
absolutely exuberant in a life because
it is just this one thing that this is
not forever this is just for a brief
period of time and the more joyful you
are briefer it becomes if you're
ecstatic it will just vanish in no time
yes so if you want to stretch it you
need to make yourself truly miserable
otherwise it'll be just gone in no time
if you come to terms with this if you
live this way that every moment you
appreciate one thing and only one thing
because the most important thing in your
life is you're alive right now to be
alive fully alive 100% alive is the most
important thing because only if
something is 100% alive can you make it
eating something beautiful
remember 19 do the right things a human
being does not become who he is because
of his desire he becomes who he is
because of his competence so instrument
hansung your competence you just
enhancing your desire which will be just
a horrible burden to carry all the time
you just focus on enhancing the
competence of who this is rather than
enhancing your desire I am going to
become a world champion everybody wants
to become one they not
become one isn't it everybody wants to
be successful they will not be a success
unless you do the right things success
will not happen to you can I tell you a
joke
45 minutes you've got to be serious on a
certain day a man fell into a septic
tank right up till here in felt he
desperately tried to come out he could
not then he started screaming fire fire
neighbors heard this call the fire
brigade five firemen came rushing they
looked all over the place no fire then
they found this man they pulled him out
and then they asked why would you
screaming fire where is the fire the man
retorted if I said [ __ ] [ __ ] would you
come
and we're to do the right things
otherwise the right things will not
happen to you just because you have a
big desire you're not going to get there
you got to do the right things
rule number 20 or in success various
situations in your life either you can
use it to make yourself stronger and
better or you can sit and cry this is
the choice you have everything it
doesn't matter what happens the most
horrific event happened in your life
that also can be used for your growth
and your well-being if only if you have
clearly seen the small events of your
life when I say small events I mean your
business your marriage your children all
those big things all these things are
just a stepping stone so the fear of
failure failure is bad enough fear is
adding spice to it isn't it success
happens to you not because you desire it
because you are in it everybody desires
it it comes only if you're capable of it
rule number 21 be passionate about
everything there are no right things to
do in life if you choose something and
put everything that you have into it
it'll become a great thing is it the
right thing is it the best thing when
you say is it the right thing what
you're asking is is it the best thing to
do in life there is no best thing to do
in life anything that you take up and if
you put your heart and soul into it it
becomes a great thing is it the best
thing No then what is the best thing
there is no such thing don't look at
yourself as a delhi 8 or an idiot
whatever you want to call yourself
if you're just a piece of life hmm hello
and today you're here one day will be
poop gone you are a brief life I want to
just imagine you've seen those insects
which come when it rains you know and
switch fly suppose you are that you just
came alive gone that's what you are just
compared to the span of your life the
insects life is looking so meaningless
and OOP OOP OOP and gone that's what the
rivers are thinking about you
OOP OOP OOP and gone yes or no compared
to their lifespan you are just like that
insect or less than an insect isn't it
so I am NOT somebody who ever debated he
is this the right thing to do in my life
what was needed I jumped into it because
if you are a constipated life you will
always be thinking about what to do what
not to do what to do what not to do what
is my passion what is not my passion why
the hell are you not passionate about
everything hello
why are you not passionate about
everything in the existence you're only
passionate about one thing means what
you constipated that's what it means
idiots do things that they don't like to
do suffer for their whole life because
they think it's needed or they think
it's their duty intelligent people do
what they love to do they enjoy their
life to some extent but a genius learns
to do what is needed joyfully that's
when your genius flowers because it's no
more about you now there's a limitless
way of looking at life
rule number 22 be well managed if you
try to control
the variety of situations that may pop
up in your face tomorrow morning all
that'll happen is you will become a very
limited life you would step out into the
world and do whatever that needs to be
done only if you have an assurance no
matter what you walk into you will not
lose yourself you will walk full stride
otherwise you'll only be a half a step
most human beings are half steps because
the fear of suffering if this happens
what will happen to me that happens what
will happen to me if you're well managed
within yourself you know how to manage
your thought you know how to manage your
emotion you know how to manage your body
your chemistry your energy if you know
how to manage all this what does it
matter if you walk into hell I'm asking
if you are well managed if you are a
heaven within you what does it matter
where you go he'll also will be an
interesting place to go but if you are
ill managed then you want to be in a
nice place all the time you will not
step out into anything I am NOT saying
this is wrong this is against nature
because in nature every life is aspiring
to a bee as much as it can be isn't it
every life is naturally aspiring this is
not a philosophy this is not an ideology
but you must do this or that it is
natural and intrinsic for every life
that you will do as much as it can from
an earthworm from a worm to an insect to
a bird to an animal to a tree every one
of them are trying to be full-fledged
life if you go against this simply
because of the fear of suffering then
all possibilities of exploring the
nature of being human the tremendous
immensity of being human is just lost
upon humanity today you will see this
everywhere when people say I am only
human they are talking about the
limitations of being human they are not
talking about the possibilities of being
human is
when if we are the most intelligent
species on the planet if we are the most
capable species on the planet should we
be talking about our possibilities or
should we be talking about our
limitations whenever anybody writes or
says oh we are human they are always
referring to their limitations never to
the possibilities of being human this is
because the the most fundamental things
have not been taught in our education
systems how to handle your thought and
your emotion your psychological drama
has gone out of control
it's a badly directed drama believe me
if we choose a well-directed drama you
would take you to the conclusion that
you want isn't it
because it's a badly directed drama just
about anybody can take charge of it who
is the director of your psychological
drama just about anybody isn't it
anybody can make it in your tragedy
rule number 23 build your competence
competition is a good thing if you are
incompetent and you're in competition
you will feel stressed
if you want to be in a competitive
situation the thing is you have to work
on your competence right now the problem
is you're tweaking your desire you're
not tweaking your competence this is
what has to happen that we must teach
children to tweak their competence not
their desire we are calling this
ambition we calling this goal oriented
Ness ambition means what you tweaked up
your desire you will suffer invariably
if you tweak up your competence you will
see wherever you go you are doing better
than what people expect you to so
naturally
things will go well for you competition
is not the bad thing lack of competence
is the bad thing so instead of
competence we have big desires
if you focus enough on enhancing your
competence you will see there is such
joy in breaking limitations every day
and becoming something better you don't
care a damn how somebody else is doing
rule number 24 prioritize suppose let's
say you have to cook something that's a
you know to bake a cake or if you want
to cook some rice you turn on this town
turn off this town turn understand turn
off this tap it's a long process
and of course they know won't happen so
this is the story of majority of the
spiritual seekers there off and on and
off and on and off and on Oh does it
mean to say I must be only here there
that's not it
the priority should not shift the
priority set slowly everything with the
new will slowly organize itself in that
direction
because the priority is shifting this
life does not know which way to go
it is confused every two minutes if you
change the destination on the GPS for
sure it does not know where to go isn't
it so this is what is happening and for
in most people this is why spiritual
path seems to be orders long impossible
unattainable all these things simply
because people are shifting priorities
all the time rule number 25 ride the
wave of life is it true that every other
creature on this planet a worm an insect
a bird and animal with a millionth of
our brain they're conducting their life
process quite well hello
okay when I say live process we are born
they're born just like that we grew up
they grow up we make a living they make
a living we may reproduce they reproduce
we do all this with enormous fuss they
simply do it
yes or no every simple thing we're doing
it with enormous fuss they are simply
doing it different various processes of
life and death they are doing it without
fuss we are doing everything with great
fuss is this a sign of highest level of
intelligence I'm asking we are supposed
to be the most intelligent and there is
no question that we have the most
evolved neurological process on the
planet yes we have the most evolved
neurological system that we must be able
to sense and feel and experience and
perceive understand and express things
in the highest possible way but no other
creature on the planet is struggling
like the human creature right now this
is simply because you have been given a
super supercomputer do you agree with me
that this is the most sophisticated
gadget on the planet not the iPhone the
eye
but now the question is have you read
the user's manual that's all people have
not read the user's manual for the most
complex machine on the planet and
somehow blundering through somehow
trying to use it everything is a problem
tell me one thing that human beings are
not suffering if they're poor they
suffer their poverty you make them rich
this up of the taxes if they're not
educated they suffer that put them to
school lot of suffering not married they
suffer that get them married I didn't
say anything I didn't say a thing okay
no children some people suffer that
children daily suffering so you seem to
be suffering every aspect of life so if
you offer death will you go though I
fully know you will suffer that so tell
me one thing that we are not suffering
now people we will Asif is life is
suffering no no life is not suffering
nor is it a joy it's simply there it's a
phenomena if you write it it feels
fantastic if you're crushed by it it
feels terrible so are you riding the
wave of life or are you being crushed by
it that's all the question is rule
number 26 be interested in people I say
this just a couple of weeks ago I was in
conversation with someone who is
considered some kind of an expert on
Internet affairs and social media and
all this so he's been looking at our
material in the YouTube and various
other platforms and I said ve I can give
you 50 times more than what is there you
know just people work on all the
thousands of hours of audio and video
that's there in the archive 50 times
more in a year's time we can
multiplied by 50 that much material is
there he said Satguru already what is
there here you're throwing it all over
the place it's worth a billion dollars
I said see what will I do with the
billion dollars my interest is seven
billion people I have no interest in
billion dollars what do I do with it
my interest is people remember 27 strive
for a better life as a generation if you
create a huge amount of positives
negative will become small if you create
huge amount of negatives they will
become big and positive will become
small this whole life is there has never
been a point any time and there never
will be where everything is perfect okay
there's no such thing because life is a
possibility because it's a possibility
it cannot be perfect doesn't matter what
we do there's still something more to do
always that is why it's an endless
possibility striving does not mean I
want to be a good man I want to be a
good man see being morally good he's
only good for the society not good for
the human being yes if you are morally
correct it's good for people around you
because you contained but it's not good
for this life so this life needs a
little different kind of nurture in that
context how many people in this world
are going to stop before you and may
fall dead how many people in how many
people will be set the seed that they
will be striving to be a better life
than the way they are right now
a little higher expression of life this
is all your focus should be remember 28
don't pass on bad things Japanese people
eat much less fat than the Americans and
the British because of this people
believe they have
much less incidence of cardiac arrests
less people in Japan die of heart
failures and heart attacks than they do
in UK and in United States but the
French eat a lot more fat but still they
have much less incidence of cardiac
problems compared to the British and the
Americans the Japanese people don't
drink much wine so they have much less
cardiac problems but the Italians drink
only wine and they also have much less
cardiac problems than the English and
the Americans so the deduction is it is
the English language which is the
problem
[Applause]
the English speaking which is the
problem so this has been a problem
everywhere that we try to transplant
what is happening in one place simply as
it is in another place not just
geographically and culturally even from
individual to individual that what
worked for one person we try to make it
work for another person and destroy the
person completely and fortunately this
is labeled as education mass producing
people though we are a mass of people on
this planet a huge number over seven
billion people still you were produced
individually not mass-produced are you
right from my childhood I've been
noticing this that most adults want to
teach something when they see children
all those damn things which have not
worked in their life this is one wow you
have to take with me that is from this
moment onwards in your life you will not
pass on anything that is not worked for
you to anybody else
hello even if you cannot pass on the
best things to other people at least
what is not worked for you you don't
give it to anybody will you do this this
anger work for you so don't give it to
anybody
does misery work for you this depression
work for you so if you are angry if
you're depressed you're miserable just
shut up okay and sit in one place and
handle it
remember 29 don't try to be intuitive
people start developing these things for
everything when their logic phase they
don't think that you know you want to do
something you don't know how to do it
you're not sure whether to do it or not
do it then the simple solution they're
taking is okay this finger is this this
finger is this yes no give it to the
child if you holds this yes if he holds
this is not this is not into your laugh
no I will come to you I'm not I'm going
more basic the answer is not just about
you I'm just using it now this is just
that your logic has become you know
incapable its collapsed unable to come
to your logical decision so you are
succumbing to this simple way if some
child holds your hand like this or like
this yes or no
anyway when there are two options 50% of
the time you could be right yes being
50% of the time right is not good enough
isn't it yes isn't it so I was you know
some time ago I was visiting a a
homeopathic doctor there in his clinic
they put up an ad some homeopathic
medicine which will work for all kinds
of snakebites you're living in Bombay
proverb probably it's not easy for you
where I come from snakes are everywhere
on a daily basis so I looked at this and
then I asked him how come this medicine
you're advertising that it works for all
kinds of snake bites because if you are
not already aware of this snake bites
are fundamentally of two kinds one type
venom attacks your cardiovascular system
another kind of venom attacks your
nervous system the two completely
different kind of chemicals and it works
upon your system in a different way
generally for both you have different
types of antidotes but for everything
this particular medicine is supposed to
work how is that possible so the doctor
said see in India 90% of the Indian
snakes have non poisonous so 90% of the
time it works that's not good enough
isn't it if the remaining 10% which is
crucial isn't it so
intuition don't get into this thing
about you trying to be intuitive never
try to beat you to logic is dependable
isn't it
there are moments when there is certain
clarity which has no logical explanation
at that time it's okay but you'll never
try to be intuitive if you try to be
intuitive your logical mind will become
deceptive and come to all kinds of
stupid decisions
you'll get certainly guidance voices
from the heaven you know all kinds of
voices people are hearing logic is
dependable go by it at least you won't
make a fool of yourself
rule number 30 get into nature if you
can find a place where there are no
sounds of machines and your cell phone
will not think think quietly if you can
listen to the sound of the trace the
breeze the water just the natural sounds
if you pay enough attention tremendous
things will happen to you
many times have been in the South Indian
you know they're kind of tropical
rainforests the longest have been there
through the jungle for about 23 days
alone no any kind of support no
cellphone for sure those days then not
even a torchlight and for today I ran
out of the food that I was carrying so I
lived off the forest by about 8:00 today
I lost my jacket and one half of my
shirt because I was chased by some
animals in by that whole thing I had
half a shirt and pants and I walked
through ice this is elephant country
tiger country iso tigers panthers
elephants all kinds of the wild buffalo
various kinds of animals very close
quarters but
at the end of it when you look back what
is the biggest impact on you
it's the insects it's in the nights the
orchestra that goes on in the rainforest
it's unbelievable and the timing every
day night 2:15 means one group will stop
another group will start really the
sense of time every day exactly by the
second one group will start and a group
will start you don't know what they're
talking about they're definitely talking
something that you don't know for sure
they're not just making dumb noises so
if you just sit there and listen and
listen and listen and listen
Roli you start noticing there is a
pattern and an organization to this
which is far bigger than any human
symphonies that you can achieve far more
complex and far more intense I think
it's really important for every human
being particularly if you have children
vacation need not be Disneyland I'm not
against it but one trip is enough all
silly stuff which excites you
vacation should be into nature if you
can take and children walk in a jungle
not in a resort just live on a mountain
expose them to nature I will tell you
you will bring up your children not only
physically healthy mentally healthy far
more sensible and accepting and
wonderful kind of human beings if they
know how to because once you go into
nature who's and you are whose daughter
you are what are you in the city doesn't
matter okay it's very important that
everybody experiences that otherwise you
start creating your own illusions as to
who you are and you start believing it
for sure
rule number 31 turn off the problems
it's time to understand all the problems
of individual nature are generated from
with him and we don't have to solve
problems that we create we just have to
dissolve no problems that you create you
don't have to solve if there is a
problem in the situation yes we have to
solve but you have a problem within you
solution is not what you need solution
is madness solution means for an
illusion you're creating an illusionary
solution something that you make up for
that you create one more solution that
you made up once again now you just have
to turn off the problems you're going
through a certain drama only thing is
you're a lousy director that's all there
is instead of improving your direction
now you are trying to find a solution
for a situation in a drama it's like
people watch the cinema and come home
and they have big arguments about what
happened there
so the thoughts and emotions that you
create you don't have to find any
solution for it you should just turn it
off it's gone if you find solution you
moving towards insanity because you
create a ghost and you create a
Ghostbuster the ghost that you create
you must learn to play with them hello
I'm saying if nobody willing to play
with you you have to play with somebody
right so the ghosts you create if you
like them you play with them if you
don't like them turn them off but
Sadhguru to keep coming
[Applause]
you don't play don't like to play with
them don't play they come and go
never it ever happen that one thought
remained for more than a moment isn't it
it comes and goes comes and goes
let it come and go if you try to find a
solution for that you will head towards
insanity
rule number 32 unleash your potential I
told the story of a Maine who had wings
but never used them to fly and just
reproduce and had a life and is it a
tragedy that he never used his wings to
fly do you feel like most of us are
walking through life with wings and we
never use them to fly unfortunately yes
a whole lot of people too many people
mm-hmm it's time that human potential is
unleashed because we are the first
generation on the planet for whom our
survival is organized better than ever
before ever so this is the time to
unlock our potential to lose those all
kinds of inhibitions and fears that we
had there was a time if as much as a
cloud gathered and lightning and thunder
happened we thought God was angry with
us okay okay all those things are gone
it is time you take away the nonsense
that's happening within you and the
entire process the science of inner
engineering is just this how to work at
it in a scientific manner not with
philosophy I can tell you a thousand
times give up your fear it's not going
to go but if your chemical soup is
blissful there's not even a
idea fear in your mind it reminds me of
your concept of the movies you play the
movies in your mind you can choose a
drama you can choose a horror story or
you can choose a positive movie and not
get stuck in the same movie forever you
can turn it off and start a new one yeah
but for that you should know where the
switches are right you are like a
supercomputer but you haven't found the
keyboard yet time to find the keyboard
that's my work to give people the
keyboard to their supercomputer remember
33 seek knowledge see the reason the
only reason a human being will seek to
know something is because he realizes
that he does not know if he does not
realize that he does not know there will
be no longing to know there will be no
seeking to know and definitely there
will be no knowing it's not possible
whether it is spiritual seeking or any
other kind of knowledge you will seek
only because you realize you do not know
if you think you know everything or you
believe you know everything you will be
just too full of yourself that's all and
that is a huge problem that's a very big
problem though we have a culturally
cultivated humility that you see all
over the place everybody is like this
only but still too full of yourself when
you bend nothing goes out of your head
it doesn't make any space I am saying
because my head is open that's why I'm
bandaged can you see rule number 34 to
be truthful to yourself one thing that
you must do to yourself is you are
absolutely truthful to yourself if
you're also truthful to everybody around
you you will get other kinds of benefits
with people but I will not go that far
right now with yourself you're 100%
truthful otherwise all kinds of tricks
keep happening
to be truthful to yourself is not a easy
thing because there is lifetimes of
habit of simply both yourself our guest
came to Shankaran Pillai house and being
a South Indian man down south you know
villas come from further down south he
was carrying an umbrella which is common
thing in Kerala and southern Tamil Nadu
to carry a nun realize a very common
thing because rains can be very heavy
then they walked out he took the guest
out then he started raining that
Shankaran Pillai did not open the
umbrella the guests said why don't you
open the umbrella
Shankaran Pillai said I'm sorry number
lights full of holes then the guests
asked why did you bring it well I never
thought it will rain today a whole lot
of people are like this they think
somebody else has to catch their lives
this will take a long time because
someone else catching your life will
take lifetimes you must catch them you
should not let your chickens pass to
become 100 percent straight with
yourself you take a certain amount of
application but if this one thing you do
I saw Thomas Atacama this piece of life
will work for sure 100 percent then
figuring out a few things is very simple
for that I'm there if you just fix one
this this one thing that you're 100
percent straight no any kind of
deception then there's a hole in the
umbrella you know there is a hole in the
umbrella you will never forget that
there is a hole in number Allah okay
if you are like this rest of the work
becomes very simple and easy
rule number 35 make the best out of
everything how to address the larger
issues of my life there are no large
issues in your life what is the large
issue that you are talking about it is
just about what job to take which girl
to marry aluminum's
where to go for vacation rather whether
to get married or not get married you
know little things isn't it these are
not large issues these are the little
things in your life yes or is it just a
small thing whom I get married to I am
NOT saying it's a small thing but as an
issue it's a small issue little issue as
a consequence to your life yes it has
many things but this is something that
human beings have done for millions of
years we have enough experience on these
things society we know that whatever job
we take whoever we marry it is just a
way we make out of it every experience
of life you can make it an enriching
experience every experience in your life
you can make a curse out of it see there
is nothing wrong in your job
whatever job you're doing there's
nothing wrong getting this job there's
nothing along wrong in losing this job
there's nothing wrong in getting married
there's nothing wrong in getting
divorced there is nothing wrong in not
getting married there is nothing wrong
in anything there is nothing wrong in
this or that but it is just that you
make misery out of it that's wrong if
you do this you make misery out of it if
you do that you make misery out of it
that's what is wrong with you
so you got married is it wrong that's
not the point there's nothing wrong with
it you did not get married is it wrong
no there's nothing wrong with it that's
wonderful - you got do it is it wrong
no that's also wonderful it is just that
you make misery out of everything that's
what is wrong you just address that one
issue everything will be settled rule
number 36 live a full fledged life
people are always thinking that
something else if somebody else is
restricting their freedom but once
freedom is lost simply because they are
tangled up with their own body and their
own mind these are two dimensions of you
two faculties unless your body and your
mind is fully in your hands if they're
continuously working for you never
against you only then you can live a
successful life people have approached
in a well being either with belief
systems or philosophies or ideologies or
some wacky ideas of their own it's time
to approach your inner well-being in a
scientific manner as the science and
technology to create external well-being
there is a whole science and technology
to create inner well-being that is what
we call as calling as inner engineering
technologies for well-being it is time
that you approach your inner well-being
also in a scientific systematic way and
employed technologies to create this
well-being everything else using
technology you understand that
technology can facilitate everything on
the outside why don't you understand
that does the best piece of technology
on this planet is this human mechanism
unless you approach it properly it will
not eat living here is half a human
being is not good enough right now
people's idea of success is they are
doing better than their neighbor now
your idea of success should be that you
are a full fledge life because this is
not my idea this is not my philosophy
this is the longing of every life every
worm insect bird tree animal and also a
human being are always striving to
become a full-fledged black but we know
what is a full-fledged worm we know what
is a full-fledged insect we know what is
a full-fledged apple tree but we don't
know what's a full-fledged human being
that's where the problem is
rule number 37 don't conquer embrace the
purpose of business or the purpose or
the goals of big business is to expand
you can expand in two different ways one
is by conquest another is by embrace I
can conquer you or I can embrace you
both ways you will become mine if I
embrace you you will become mine
willingly and I will have better use of
you in every possible way I am talking
business not just as my personal thing
but if I concur you I will still have
you but I have to sit on top of your
head and make you do things and you will
do everything possible to make my life
miserable
yes or not true absolutely so people are
trying to conquer and their businesses
and their activity is doing everything
possible to make them miserable and you
can see it on their faces successful
people are showing miserable faces which
is a wrong message to send to the world
particularly to the youth if you send a
message that success is misery you're
destroying humanity success is the
sweetest thing that can happen to you
human being but now you take the most
successful 10,000 people on the planet
you will see there are an epitome of
tension and anxiety and misery you are
sending a completely wrong message this
you can see took such a bad turn in
United States of America in the 60s the
so called corporates brutally wanting to
grow conquer the world set such an image
of themselves
the youth thought it's better to sit in
the street corner and smoke pot and it's
a better way to live at least you're
happy you're not causing any damage to
anybody this is a horrible way to exist
so it's extremely important that
successful people send a clear message
success is a beautiful thing it is not a
suffering it is not a miserable thing to
do in your life
if this has to happen your expansion has
to happen by embrace not by conquest
rule number 38 find stability spiritual
process means to become like a mountain
stable still because it's only when
somebody has a very stable base many
things can be done the exuberance of
life is possible only if there is
absolute stability otherwise exuberance
will lead to madness
yes that's why a lot of people what a
little creative little active little
exuberant always end up being freaky and
utterly insane because without stability
you cannot have a dance going this is
why save I mean stillness Shiva means
dance at the same time either you see
him sitting absolutely still or you say
man an explosion of dance because an
explosion is possible only when there is
a stable base an explosion which is not
destructive is possible only when there
is stability and stability people try to
become stable by controlling and
trimming their lives this is the way
your grandmother would tell you how to
be stable control yourself then you will
be stable yes if you're dead you will be
stable very I promise you that so
normally people who talk about stability
are all constipated existence you know
what's constipation that means it
happens little by little
[Music]
their joy their love their ecstasy
happens little by little here and there
that's constipation so stability is not
because you have trimmed your life down
or pruned it down to minimal and you're
stable that's of no consequence
stability because you see everything are
totally clearly that is why when we say
odd yogi we're talking about stability
at the same time an exuberant dance this
is possible only because here's more
than two eyes not necessarily three more
than two that means this is much more
than most people ever see because he
sees much much more able to be stable
stability it takes to allow exuberance
to happen otherwise you keep curtailing
your exuberance because it hurts when
it's out of balance if you are out of
balance and you move at a certain speed
you're going to hurt yourself whether
you are riding a bicycle or you riding
the cosmos if you are out of balance and
you attain speed you're going to hurt
yourself very badly so balance is very
important and balance that comes out of
curtailment is not balance that's you
know package death
rule number 39 reduce friction so you
must understand this if everything that
you try to do is becoming friction
friction is happening obviously you're
the sandpaper know it's a sin people
I'll ask them to provide you a sample a
small piece every day whenever you have
a friction with somebody just scrape
your skin some rock so if you don't cure
yourself quickly you won't have any skin
left when you don't have any skin left
then you will not touch anything
you will not create it you will not look
for any friction you will walk in
suppose you had no skin how would you
walk even a little feather won't touch
you like that you will walk isn't it
because everything hurts now so if you
want that kind of treatment we can do
otherwise first come to your senses
friction is happening means wherever you
go friction is happening obviously too
one simple thing you can do to reduce
friction is I have told you many times
but you've not done this ease whatever
you're saying in a day or in an hour for
in a minute how many words per minute
are you uttering bring it down to 50%
still do the same work you will see a
whole lot of friction will go down
simply because you are not blabbering
yes and we've been trying to train you
whatever you see whether you see a man
woman child cow donkey donkey also
no I will friction not happen it will
happen so when you insert the gurus here
like this first of the time like this it
won't work bring this into you not just
as a symbolism genuinely so friction of
two kinds one within ourselves outside
is just an expression and the
consequence so this whole thing about in
engineering means just this that when
you sit here you can sit here without
any friction if you can sit here without
any friction outside friction also will
go down but when you meet a sandpaper
there must be some friction there are
sand papers hello so when you meet the
sand paper there must be friction
otherwise how there will be so generally
we award at the sand paper if we can but
sometimes we have to work with them when
we have to work with the sand paper you
need tact this is something you have to
learn this will not come this is nothing
spiritual about it this is attacked in
the society sometimes it doesn't work
but it's a question of skill some people
who are not spiritual in any way they
are very tactful when they meet sand
papers you will see this kind of agents
and others or working in government
offices and in political atmospheres
they are so smooth it doesn't matter how
rough the other person is these people
just just get the job done and leave
so working with sandpaper takes a little
bit of skill and experience nothing
spiritual about it it's a social skill
but generally in the are some very few
sent papers once in a way people pop ups
and on them but they drop it you know
they don't keep it all the time
sometimes sometimes they're like that
they're not like that all the time so
when they are like that when the
porcupine has its thing up you must just
keep away a bit when it's done you can
talk to it it doesn't keep it up all the
time it doesn't have the strength to do
that so your friction
you must understand it's just you rule
number 40 tell great stories on a
certain day a bull and a pheasant were
grazing bull was chomping the grass
pheasant was picking off picking ticks
off the bull partnership the huge tree
at the edge of the field
the pheasant very nostalgically looked
at the tree and sad or last there was a
time I could fly to the topmost branch
of the tree now I do not have enough
strength in my wing even to get to the
first branch the bull very nonchalantly
said that's no issue just eat a little
bit of my tongue every day within a
fortnight you'll get there
pheasant said come on what kind of
rubbish is that the bull said really try
and see the whole humanities on it
so very hesitantly the pheasant started
pecking at that down and low on the very
first day trees the first branch of the
tree within a fortnight it reached the
topmost branch of the tree just
beginning to enjoy the scenery an old
farmer I was rocking on his rocking
chair saw a fat old pheasant sitting on
top of the tree pulled out his shotgun
and shot the bird off the tree the moral
of the story is many times even [ __ ]
can get you to the top but it never lets
you stay there rule number 41 do what
you want
yeah if you're postponing something
you're obviously doing something that
you don't want to do if there is
something that you really want to do
will you postpone it or pre pon it hello
do you see somebody is waiting for
someone they badly want to see only ten
minutes in the ten minutes they will
look at the watch 25 times why they want
to propone it you are doing something
that you don't want to do so you want to
postpone it I'm asking why the hell are
you doing something that you don't want
to do no because if I do this I will get
that I will get that that's not the
point there is nothing to get in this
life there's really nothing to get in
this life either you live this life in a
profound and intense manner or you did
not what will you get in the end if
somebody dies in the Agricultural
College do they bury them or fire them
how is it
what's the tradition burying is good for
agriculture because human beings make
good men you so in the end what will
happen to you and me they will either
barriers or bonus that's all will happen
in the end you think something else
they'll give you a price
nothing will happen in the end
only thing is the process of life how
wonderfully did you live that's all
there is so if you are doing something
really wonderful do you want to pre pawn
it or postpone it 3 pawn only so you
must find what is it that you really
want to do if you find that one thing
you will always propone everything not
postpone rule number 42 become wise this
happened in 1941 this is just when the
Nazi moment was building up in Germany
and in some parts of Europe so one day
in Austria a bunch of German soldiers
came broke into the homes the Jewish
family a rich family they brought the
home and took away the others took
everything was robbed and these two
children a 12 year old girl and a 8 year
old boy were taken away they were taken
to a railway station this the month of
number n December kind of time when he's
becoming very cold so they were kept in
the railway station for three days
because the trains did not come boys
little boys being boys they started
playing football so they were playing
football and then suddenly the train
came the train is not a passenger train
it's a cargo train the goods train so
when the train came the soldiers came
and rushed everybody into the wagons
which are there everybody got in and the
little boy and the girl also got in but
the little boy forgot to wear his shoes
he left his shoes outside and they
pushed him into the wagon so without
shoes he came his sister a
twelve-year-old girl saw her kid brother
coming without shoes and she got mad
with him she held him by the year boxes
years scolded him nicely slapped them
say you idiot already we are in enough
trouble
now you come without shoes because in
Germany in wind
no shoes means you may lose your feet so
she's angry about that in the next
station the boys and girls were
separated after four years after the war
was over she came out of the
concentration camp to find 17 members of
her family including her little brother
all had vanished no records no sign of
them
they just evaporated at that time the
only thing that bothered her was the
last few things that she said to her
little brother she loves her brother but
the last few things that she said to him
for such terrible things it rang in her
mind and troubled her these are the last
things I told my brother and after that
I'm never going to see him it's gone so
she took a vow if I speak to anybody in
my life I will speak in such a way if
this is my last word I will not regret
this one thing transformed her life in
such a way she went on to United States
she died in 2006 she did some phenomenal
work built a hospital somewhere near
Chicago I think she lived a fruitful
life I'm saying even if you put through
the most horrible situations either you
can come out using that experience is a
better human being or you can use the
experience to become a horrible mess so
whenever something hurts you there are
two options you can either become
wounded or you can become wise this is
the choice the more things hurt you
early on in your life the wiser you
should have become isn't it but
unfortunately most people become wounded
this is simply because they just need an
excuse to turn their own intelligence
against themselves that's all especially
if the world around you turns against
you is it not very very important
that your intelligence stands up for you
rule number 43 control your mind around
us so many people will do so many things
that we don't like yes or no so many
things in Mumbai happening things that
we don't like that every day happening
but at least within you only what you
want should happen within this isn't it
huh I cannot decide that only what I
want should happen with you but I can
definitely decide only what I want must
happen within me isn't it if you could
decide only what you want should happen
within you would you choose anger or joy
what's your choice please choose I'm
gonna bless you see you want the highest
level of pleasantness for yourself isn't
it then why is such a thing not
happening as I said earlier you never
read the user's manual how this
functions has not been looked at do not
go by the example of people who came
here a few few years earlier than you
that no no my mother also has like that
my grandmother also was getting angry so
I am also getting angry they should not
be the leading lights of your life I
want you to look at it your thought your
emotion your body must happen the way
you want isn't it if somebody else can
decide what should happen within you
this is ultimate slavery isn't it so
what happens around you maybe we can
decide but nobody should decide except
yourself what happens within you if you
decide you would keep this in the
highest state of pleasantness for sure
you wouldn't be battling with anger it's
not just about anger fear stress tension
don't address them separately
essentially your mind is not taking
instructions from you why because you
don't know where the damn keyboard is
yet
we gave you a supercomputer you do not
know where where the keyboard is so one
day you did this something work another
day you did this something work you know
have you seen people the radio doesn't
work boom and it works sometimes that's
not a technology that's chance have you
seen this if something doesn't work
people think cap top top it'll work and
a lot of people are using this for human
beings also rule number 44 work for your
own well-being the fear of suffering is
not just about pain the fear of
suffering is self-inflicted nobody can
cause mental pain to you it is you in
reaction to something that happens
around you that you cause pain to
yourself if you have half your brain
removed then you would see you would be
quite peaceful right now people are
going through stress anxiety depression
misery all kinds of things you can give
it any number of exotic names that you
want but essentially their intelligence
is turned against them that's all it is
once your intelligence is against you
there is no force on the planet or
anywhere which can save you so the
fundamental thing is to bring this that
all the faculties that we have should
work for our well-being right now our
own body our own mind our own emotions
are working against us this one thing
has to be fixed this is the machine
rule number 45 study your opponent this
happened in the 98 99
Andrea Gussie and Boris Becker played
three games all Boris Becker beat Andrea
gauzy because he had such a you know he
was called boom-boom because Boris
Becker called boom-boom because of the
service his service was so powerful
there was no game every time he will
serve serve and finish the game nobody
returns the ball so
and regazzi went back and studied
hundreds of hours of Boris Becker's
serves then he figured it out
then in the next three years he played
11 games with him and beat him on 10 of
them I'll tell you what happened after
Boris Becker retired they met in Germany
there's something called the Oktoberfest
in Germany they were there and at that
time they were together and then dragged
as he thought okay anyway he's retired
now I can tell him because this bothered
Boris pick a big time nobody can beat
him but this guy's getting at him so he
told him see I observed your videos
continuously and I figured out that
whenever you are serving the ball
towards the boundary line Boris Becker
if you know when he is serving his
tongue sticks out a little bit when he
throws the ball up and comes down his
tongue sticks out said whenever you are
serving towards the boundary line your
tongue goes to the left when you're
serving straight it comes out straight I
observed this the moment your tongue
sticks out to the boundary line I was
already there every time taking the ball
so Boris Becker literally fell off his
chair he couldn't believe this and he
said any number of times I went home
after the matches and I told my wife he
seems to be reading my mind but you've
been reading my tongue
it's almost poking so your opponent
should be never unfamiliar to you you
must make him familiar you must know him
better than he knows himself
rule number 46 make life better this is
to be a little context we saw the videos
that we need an economist be okay so in
that context how do you keep yourself on
the move all the time on the go you
don't have to be on the go all the time
if life demands people ask me so true
how are you active like it's because
generally my schedule is anywhere
between 18 to 20 hours a day seven days
of the week 365 days non-stop for many
years it's going on I'm complaining and
the guys clapping about it so people
keep asking how do you keep yourself
like this how do you do this see I'm
essentially lazy it's just that the
situation in the world demands action
left to myself I would close my eyes and
simply said I made like this if I close
my eyes I can sit like this till I fall
dead really I have really no need for
action I am NOT trying to keep myself
busy there's a lot to be done so you're
doing people ask me such guru what's
your dream what is your dream I said my
dream is the day I am unemployed that's
a great day because if I am unemployed
it simply means everybody is doing
fantastic what more do you want
dream fulfilled so action is not
something that you decide you just
decide your intent action the world will
decide how much of what I am you know at
these Economic Forum's instead I am at
the World Economic Forum this guy from
business schools in Howard Business
School one professor comes oh you're
that amazing tree planter I said no I am
NOT a tree planter
you sure no no you planted those
millions of T's yes I did but I am NOT a
tree planter then what do you do I said
I make people flower not plain trees but
I'm planting trees because the goddamn
trees are missing where they should have
been where they should have been they
are not there it's like this
two men were working on the street one
man is digging pits behind him another
man is coming and closing and closing
and going somebody else was driving by
they saw this ridiculous activity one
guy digs the pit another guy closes the
pit so they stopped and said hey what
are you doing here why you guys working
like this one guy digging another at
closing they said no no the in-between
guy has gone and leave he is the tree
planter he's not there we're doing our
work so a lot of people are doing work
like I am doing my work you have no work
on this planet the planet needs work if
the world needs work we will do it
otherwise why should I think this is my
work
so it's good what's your mission it's an
omission I'm just fooling around a bit
because you have no business to have
your own mission life has its own
mission in some way if you can assist
and serve that that's about it what is
it that you have your own mission are
you some kind of a tyrant all
machineries are tyrants in some way
unknowingly yes those who think they
have a mission there is no mission what
is needed you do especially when you
study in a business school and get
certain competence to manage things or
create things you must create what is
needed not create some rubbish and push
it on them yes yes or no you may see how
to make life better how to solve
situations which are problematic to a
whole lot of people you must look for
solutions and solutions for the existing
situations and
there are experts who go on creating new
problems so you will never be short of
problems believe me you just have to
create solutions not go on a mission
mode that's for Mussolini rule number 47
take control of your life what people
are generally calling as destiny is
essentially what they end up creating
unconsciously when I say unconsciously
as you sit here right now as everybody
sits here right now there is physical
activity going on within the system
there is mental process there is
emotional activity and of course the
life energies are active every moment
they are taking in hundreds of inputs
whether you're conscious are not
conscious so if I ask you a question
since this morning from the time you
woke up till now of these four
dimensions of activity how much have you
conducted consciously what percentage do
you think few things how much percentage
do you think 25 you're very generous man
it's well below 1% if you walk from
there to there there will be 25
different kind of smells that you're not
conscious of the body registers and
records there are 100 different kinds of
sounds that the body registers that you
are not conscious of like this
throughout the day and night in
wakefulness and sleep this is happening
when you are only conscious of less than
1% of your activity definitely life will
look like an accident
hello when 99% of the things that you're
doing you're doing unconsciously
definitely life look will look
accidental if the accident see it is so
happened somebody fell off on the street
and had a brain injury after that
suddenly they started working their
mathematics in a wonderful way but that
was only one a thousand other people who
cracked their skull
never recovered from that or they died
or those who lived on lived on much
diminished so being accidentally
fortunate is not the way to exist
so whenever a pleasant accident happens
we say it's destiny
some of you even say God doing things to
me
when did you make a partnership with him
I don't know so shall I tell you a story
ok this happened Sherlock Holmes
you know Sherlock Holmes and Watson went
out camping and early morning
3:30 a.m. Sherlock Holmes nudged Watson
the open is nice what what do you see he
asked well I see a clear sky and stars
what does it mean to you he said well
that means tomorrow is going to be a
wonderful sunny day then yes what does
it mean to you
that it means someone has stolen our
tent so we don't know what went missing
and something may fall here and there by
chance but that's not the way life works
if a human being doesn't take it upon
himself or herself to make their own
destiny they're still having an
evolutionary problem that is they are
still not yet fully there because being
human means this that we can conduct our
life consciously being human means this
that we can craft our life the way we
want but this destiny business is a good
insurance to handle your failure
whenever you fail destiny so God's will
rule number 48 become
the-best-version-of-yourself
just because somebody is successful this
doesn't mean that figured out everything
this doesn't mean they're at ease with
life this doesn't mean their life is in
some way fulfilled no because today our
idea of success is just doing little
better than somebody else you doing
little better than somebody else means
and you're very happy about that
what it means is you're actually
enjoying other people's failures if
somebody enjoys another person's failure
or I call that sickness
not success what do you call it hello I
[Music]
[Applause]
enjoyed that you failed this is sickness
this is not success isn't it
unfortunately this is half your coin
this is the reason why human potential
is not unleashed because if you are
racing with a lame person you just happy
you're one step ahead of him only when
you meet missile Bold you understand who
the hell you are
yes till then you think you are a great
Runner because other person doesn't have
legs
rule number 49 don't fear suffering you
did this activity where to get us awake
and energized you had us close our eyes
and you count to three and then we had
to yell lose our inhibitions and and let
it all out and that idea of kind of
losing control losing traditions for me
personally has actually been a challenge
and I was hoping to get your perspective
I have never done drugs because I don't
want to lose control I fight roller
coasters because I don't like losing
control the body I'm excited for your
perspective I don't know why it it came
up because last night I did my best but
it's always been a challenge or a
struggle for me and I'm just curious to
get your perspective nature has imposed
substantial amount of restrictions on
life
you can just zoom off into the space
there is enough restrictions you don't
have to invent your own restrictions on
top of it so if you invent your own
restrictions slowly over a period of
time you become a constipated life that
means life won't happen easy it happens
in small happenings so being in a state
of abandoned not out of control being in
a state of abandoned means all the stops
that you have put on yourself you pulled
it off
native stops are still there there for
your safety and your well-being but why
are you imposing stops there's enough
gravity is holding you down that's bad
enough now you want to hold yourself
down why because fear what is the fear
about the fear is always about if I do
this I may suffer so that is a
fundamental of my work to bring you to
your place where there's no fear of
suffering and rule number 50 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
get drunk on life as a child did you
blow so bubbles so bubbles so when you
blew so bubbles
have you seen somebody got this big
bubble you got only this big bubble we
must hold our breath and leave it slow
then we'll get a bit everybody had air
in the lungs but somebody got a big
bubble somebody got a small bubble what
is this about see when it comes to body
this is my body that is your body 100%
clear no confusion about this isn't it
this is my body that is your body this
is my mind that is your mind but when it
comes to life there is no such thing as
my life and your life this is a living
cosmos how much life will you capture
within your system will determine the
size and scope of your life
somebody got a big bubble somebody else
got a small bother OOP it went off you
cannot identify where is my air and
where is your air is something so
similarly when it comes to life there is
no such thing as my life and your life
but distinctly my body and your body my
mind and your mind but no my life and
your life there is life abundant life
this is a living cosmos how much life
will you capture within yourself will
determine the scope and range of your
life what one person can do in 100 years
somebody may do it in 10 years because
of the sheer intensity of life when I
say intensity of life it may translate
in many different ways
see there are times for example certain
businesses have grown let us say some
business like you know in United States
this become a fad within three
somebody's billions of dollars worth of
business let us say Microsoft has grown
or Facebook has grown or something like
this has grown this is largely because
of technological breakthroughs and
somebody writes that technology at
another time that would not have
happened so that is different but if you
want to create something really large
really significant larger small is not
the point significance then you need
intensity of life one thing is the scale
of life that you capture there are this
is what I said earlier when I said yoga
obliterating in boundaries of your
individuality means in a way you are
allowing universe to invade you when
universe is not against you but it
invades you or it's a part of you then
you have abundance of life when you have
abundance of life you will not hesitate
to share when you share big time your
life with everybody else people will
naturally value it immensely because
everybody is trying to hold it somebody
is willing to share it so naturally
there will be a big upsurge around you
this will lead to many things this will
make many friends and many enemies a lot
of people whom you have never met there
your sown enemies but you don't know why
you never met them you never had a word
with them but they are swearing that I
am his enemy I don't know why but it
goes on in the world so when we talk
about how so much can be done in a short
span of time it's not a short span of
time it's 37 years incessant work seven
days of the week 20 hours a day almost
for 25 years
more than 25 years on an everyday I
slept only for two and a half hours a
day not deprived of sleep just kept my
life and it is so intense that sleep was
not even an issue there are times when
I've gone without sleep for three days
four days full scale working not because
you're on some kind of a drug and not
sleeping simply because of the intensity
of purpose and commitment to what you're
doing today I can proudly say I have
created thousands of people around me
all of them have gotten crazy like that
they are beginning to work like this
most of them you don't know when they
will sleep when they will wake up on on
on seven days of the week no holidays no
vacations but everybody is joyful if you
come to the yoga center and see you will
see the most joyful faces but they've
never been on a vacation they don't own
a damn thing they don't have money in
their pockets but they're just joyful
because drunk with life literally now
I've got a special bonus script from
Sadhguru on how to stop raising the bar
of survival that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what are you gonna do today to get drunk
on life number two what can you do every
week to become more wise and number
three how can you make the best of a
negative situation you're facing right
now let's say taking United States as an
example this is not going to be the
problem of only United States United
States has come first in the race
okay others will get it because they're
all going the same way right now us is a
stock example one thing is we go on
raising the bar for survival we must
define this is survival this means
you're good enough after this it must be
exploration of what you really wish to
do but we keep on raising the bar of
survival in such a way now even after
becoming the most affluent nation a
whole lot of people are just struggling
for survival this is senseless and
affluence affluence means your survival
is done thing isn't it but like you just
mentioned they're working three jobs to
survive this is not affluence this is
horrible poverty at least in India we
can sit back and enjoy
so the way we have structured the
society right now is people have a 35
year house mortgage I mean if you have a
35 year economic commitment to something
tomorrow even if God popped up here you
can't change the direction of your life
because the bank is here what will you
do because largely you're all from
Christian communities so I am saying if
Jesus popped up tomorrow and he says
come follow me
you're not going because we got monthly
payment time you got bills to pay
insurance to pay you can't change this
is a silly way of organizing our lives
the question the very reason why we want
to become affluent is so that depending
upon what Life offers us we can change
the direction of our life whenever we
want isn't it isn't it very important
this is one thing that has to sink into
the American people being the most
affluent nation means you are not
battling for survival this is happening
because you are raising the bar of
survival endlessly no matter what you do
you're still only fighting for survival
if this one thing we change then we can
do lot of things about health and
well-being and beyond that and if you
want more Sadhguru check out the
interview that I did with him one on one
right here in this location I think
you'll enjoy the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there
nobody can cause mental pain to you it
is you in reaction to something that
happened
you